sind das die radikalen gotteskrieger vor
denen die welt sich fürchtet ausgelassen
feiernde kämpfer in einem fitnessstudio
die taliban fahren karussell mit diesen
aufnahmen eines ruhigen kabuls wollen
sie ein bild der versöhnung zeichnen
öffentlich versprechen sie frieden eine
generalamnestie und schulbildung auch
für mädchen darf man ihnen trauen
ich denke dass die taliban momentan
signalisieren dass sie pragmatischer
geworden sind da muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein denn pragmatischer
bedeutet nicht dass sie ihre ideologie
geändert haben die taliban
konservativ ultra religiös gewaltbereit
ihre geschichte reicht zurück bis in die
besatzungszeit der sowjets in den 80er
jahren die usa unterstützen die
muslimischen widerstandskämpfer die
mudschaheddin mit geld und waffen
1989 geben die sowjets auf und
afghanistan versinkt in einem
bürgerkrieg der bis heute anhält dieser
unübersichtlichen lage formiert sich
eine gruppe radikaler kämpfer die
taliban sie erobern 1996 nach blutigen
schlachten das land unterrichten eine
schreckensherrschaft
frauen müssen sich komplett verschleiern
musik ist verboten es gibt öffentliche
hinrichtungen
der elfte september macht klar die
taliban gewähren internationalen
terroristen wie al qaida unterschlupf
eine koalition unter führung der usa
besetzt afghanistan doch die taliban
sind nicht besiegt also ich glaube dass
die taliban immer existiert haben dass
wir das nicht so wahr haben wollten und
dass wir uns selber eingeredet haben das
die taliban verschwunden sind die
taliban sind tief verankert religiöser
und sozialer in den paschtunischen
stammesgebieten der afghanischen
regierung ist es nie gelungen auf
ländliche regionen wie diese einfluss zu
nehmen die provinz wardak zwei
autostunden südwestlich von kabul die
aufnahmen sind vor der jüngsten
offensive der taliban entstanden die
gotteskrieger kontrollieren dieses dorf
seit zwölf jahren haben bereits ein
kleines emirat errichtet die
zentralregierung gilt hier als
schwerfällig und korrupt deswegen haben
die taliban den alltag übernommen halten
auch gerichtsverhandlungen abbringen die
akten her und deine papiere
vor gericht steht ein kämpfer der seine
waffe außerhalb der gefechte benutzt
haben soll
also warum hast du in die luft
geschossen ich wusste nicht dass das
verboten ist
sprich lauter du hast geschossen warum
um eine hochzeit zu feiern
ja das war der anlass
damit hast du die vorschriften des
emirats verletzt die taliban regeln das
leben bis ins kleinste detail
schulbildung verkauf von lebensmitteln
und wie oft die menschen am tag beten
müssen frauen auf den straßen sieht man
kaum
2013 betreten die taliban erstmals
internationales parkett mit der
unterstützung katars eröffnen sie in
doha die politische kommission ihr
hauptquartier ein diplomatischer erfolg
die eröffnungsfeier lassen sie filmen
sichtlich stolz auf das erreichte
[Musik]
das image der taliban wird uns nicht
gerecht
wenn die welt uns die chance gibt zu
zeigen wer wir sind und was wir wollen
werden viele sehr überrascht sein
[Musik]
in den 90er jahren verbieten die taliban
noch das fernsehen jetzt sind sie im
internet präsent in ihren beiträgen auf
paschtu dari englisch und arabisch
präsentieren sie fundamentalismus in
neuem gewand sie definieren sich immer
noch als gegenpol zur moralischen
korruption des westens öffnen sich aber
für technische errungenschaften
sie machen das jetzt etwas besser weil
sie natürlich auch vom erfolg anderer
dschihadisten gelernt haben und weil sie
wissen dass bei der internationalen
darstellung ihrer eigenen erfolge
soziale medien auch eine wichtige rolle
spielen und wenn überhaupt dann ist die
lektion die wir jetzt schon sehen können
dass die taliban momentan zumindest
schon darauf achten was die
internationale gemeinschaft von ihnen
denkt das jahr 2018 ist für die taliban
ein entscheidender wendepunkt in doha
beginnt die us regierung von donald
trump offizielle friedensgespräche
allerdings ohne die afghanische
regierung die amerikaner sitzen jetzt
mit männern am tisch die sie einst als
top-terroristen gejagt haben im februar
ein händedruck zwischen dem us
sondergesandten für afghanistan und
einem taliban führer ein historisches
abkommen die regierung trump garantiert
den abzug aller ausländischen truppen
aus afghanistan für die taliban ein
triumph
das ist noch kein sieg aber es zeigt
ganz klar die schwäche der amerikaner
und alle anderen länder die truppen in
afghanistan haben
der sieg allerdings lässt nicht lange
auf sich warten am 15 august übernehmen
die taliban in kabul die macht noch
allerdings versuchen sie sich einen
pragmatischen weltoffenen anstrich zu
geben
auch die pragmatische vision der taliban
ist letztlich eine fundamentalistische
vision das heißt die verlierer bei
dieser ganzen geschichte sind natürlich
vor allem frauen und männer die
fortschrittlich sind die am besten
orientiert sind für die gibt es in
afghanistan taliban egal ob pragmatisch
oder ideologisch keinen platz
der fundamentalismus ist zurück auch
wenn sich die taliban noch harmlos geben
solange die welt zuschaut